hey everyone ready player one is now in
theaters and we are here with our
in-depth review did director Steven
Spielberg capture the magic of Ernest
Cline's novel and transform the works
pop-culture obsession into something
enjoyable to watch over an even deeper
question on at the hearts and minds of
most fans is Batman because that's all
people really care about yeah he's all
over the place he's here right now right
behind you don't turn around he'll
disappear he's in here real quick this
is going to be a spoiler review so if
you haven't seen it give it a pause and
then go run out and see it and then come
back yeah it's funny right as you said
go right out and see it we heard a motor
fastest motorcycle guys this is this is
new rockstars news our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week so
we're also gonna talk about some news
from the Han Solo movie hmm
the delayed Aquaman trailer a Marvel's
Fantastic Four news and Donald Glover's
canceled Deadpool animated series we
actually got some really fun in store
for that I'm Erik Bosse joining me at
this table are saying bashers over here
and the Hawaiian shirts really cool you
guys can send me some if you'd like and
you have been to Hawaii Atlantis pun
intended available at geek balm merch
time probably I'm Phillip Molina and
this shirt I made from from threads we
talked about it earlier a tiny rickover
pickle Rick five-time pick already
played out just sayin
yeah well guys let's get started with
our top story ready player one movie is
now finally in theaters and we were
actually all fortunate to see it alone
early each of us actually have posted
our own non-spoiler reviews by ourselves
we're very lonely when we did it but you
know we have our own individual takes
that you can go watch if you don't want
to be spoiled but for here in this video
we're gonna dive deep into what works
what we think could have been better and
yeah we will try to warn you before we
discuss any spoilers but yeah yeah I
suppose I consider this a spoiler review
just so you don't get mad at us okay
let's get started with what we loved
about this movie what did Spielberg and
co-writer Ernest Cline who yeah I wrote
the book what do they get right in this
movie I think it helps sorry pre spoiler
and yeah we can we can talk about just
quick summary pre spoilers yeah
well I chose not to read the book before
this movie came out one just went
somewhere can I just find it weird that
there aren't more pictures in the book
no I I chose not to because it's got so
many references in it that I'm like you
know what let's let's see if this movie
is entertaining without it without
knowing what's gonna happen in it and I
had a blast I had a blast watching this
movie there's definitely holes we can
poke into it which we can get to in a
second and I want to hear what you guys
have to say when it comes to the
adaptation of it cuz I know there's
definitely differences which is kind of
cool because Aaron's client had such a
big hand in adapting his own novel which
doesn't really happen all the time
yeah so it's they did a great job so I
enjoyed it yeah I would say that the
movie is more fun than it is good and I
feel like I that sounds like a dig at it
but it's not it I totally agree it's
more yeah when I walked out of it I was
like what a nice time wasn't like a good
a good time if you get the references
that are being made then you're like
this is fun this is like a BuzzFeed quiz
but like with action and directed by
Spielberg so it's actually even a little
bit better than that but no no but
actually like is sometimes like it
scratches an itch that you are just in
the mood I think you go into this
knowing you're gonna have a nostalgic
experience and I think that part is like
like could not have been done better I
really don't know that this movie could
be better than it is it's just if you're
looking for like you know this amazing
piece of cinema no it's not the best
story that's ever been told but in terms
of just like revisiting your childhood
it does a really great job with that and
it's well acted and it's well directed
by some it's a bike by most most so for
me I was really worried of the overuse
of CGI because we've seen time and time
again with you know your Justice
League's and the suicide squads a little
of the time every time they lean into
CGI especially with CGI villains I just
don't think they know that anymore you
really do take away the sense of
character and the sense of risk so
throwing this entire world into the CGI
I was like I'm just not gonna feel
anything wrong wrong wrong there's so
much heart in this movie and I
really felt a lot like and I walked away
just beaming I was so happy the second
time you are you do find the floors a
little bit more and you're like ah this
is a little bit of a lull and now this
is like an exciting but overall like I
love the book and the movie for me
surpassed my expectations completely
yeah you know it's interesting this is
more of a movie than it is a film I
think right this is a popcorn movie
that's the kind of expectation you
should have going into it
Kanaka Jumanji was a surprise hit for a
lot of people it's fine right it's an
enjoyable experience and if you think
about Spielberg is the perfect director
of that yes he has like done it all
right he's been a director who's made
like very like shadows really directed
composed films works of art but he's
also the guy who made just like
enjoyable popcorn comes any reminded
Hollywood that films are meant to be
escapist fun and that's what ready
player one is if you can just like let
go of your like pretentious high
expectations as some people may not be
able to do that this isn't your movie
this is it's adapted from a young adult
novel and it's it's it's fun and yeah
sometimes I think what one thing that he
did really well is if you do read the
book you know that sometimes it's just
lists and lists of random preferences
and he's just going on pages and pages
and pages and I think Spielberg in
client's Acton did a really good job
like picking their battles and picking
specific moments that oh no this is
really gonna hit well with the audience
and this is actually gonna have some
kind of like narrative stakes or some
kind of it's gonna create a fun
spectacle rather than just like we're
gonna throw in a reference you do get me
you get a little piece of that I feel
like again having read the book but
there's a lot of the story is
researching someone's like likes and
that there's built out this world and
there's a time when two characters are
like no his 11th favorite film is a
horror film as this movie but his 10th
is this and I'm like wow I don't care
about this but it's only for a second
with the book in the movie some like
cages and you move on pretty quick from
it but that that was you know it's
amazing the movie is about this idea of
searching one man psyche for the keys
literal keys and in the movie but it's
Ernest Cline's own psyche they were
walking through and his own memories and
I remember that when we saw it
together we were like huh a lot of those
varieties references that I remember but
also a lot of these things are like
that's all you earnest flying like
especially what was the music that it
was like of course everyone listened to
only this oh it's Depeche Mode oh right
and I think it's great but like the 80s
band you know anyway it was just
interesting to be like and he was there
at the screening that we got to see and
it was like you could see him like
lighting up like all this stuff is it's
all here all once it's like oh you this
movie's for you by you but it's actually
close enough that I changed well there
there was a like there was a thing used
during the final battle that was
referenced a couple different times it
was definitely a toy but is it is that
what it is not though is it the it was
like use this as an explosive yeah which
is a toy is that a popular toy because I
don't know what I do remember it but I
was like oh that's a deep guy you use
multiple times though in the movie like
yeah no no but that that specific thing
was like they were on posters and stuff
outside and I'm like did a lot of people
know what this is but whatever yeah yeah
yes I broke my analogy here is if you
like to hook this is the 2018 version of
a lot of audiences as well where it's
like crazy it's a great movie yeah well
yeah you're right it's like up this
boyish escapism like finding your inner
child a little bit can't go a little bit
hammy with it it's all food there right
right and they break the fourth wall a
little bit on this thing that we all
loved one version of
a great example I brought up a
performances and I didn't I got mixed
reviews when I said that I thought
across the board Steven Spielberg did a
good job of getting good performances
addresses people problems for me is when
you look at just what's happening in the
movie you're like this is kind of dumb
but like I don't care because like it's
paint-by-numbers adventure story rim -
it's bad for it's bad and it's not
trying to be good it's different well
the famous thing with Spielberg is that
he tries to make global movies that you
can essentially watch with the sound
turned off and still be able to follow
the action pretty clearly and when
you're doing an adventure story like
this it's actually pretty hard
especially when it's got mystery built
in and everything but I feel like I
could watch this with anyone you know of
any age and they can basically get the
gist of it so it does have that overly
simplified thing and it's almost like a
Willy Wonka story but like well you know
with less going on and in a way just
more visuals but I think that's also
part of Spielberg's Canon when when you
go do a kid's movie he wants to make
sure everyone can access this yeah and
he does a really good job with pacing I
think like when you do read the book I
mean any book things slowed down because
you're getting into the world they're
explaining details about the character
and doing all that development with a
movie you know you want to keep things
moving quickly and Spielberg is known
for keeping his films well paced and but
this movie does have that kind of
videogame energy to it like he is trying
to make like a video game movie a movie
about video games it has the kind of
thrills that one would have when you're
playing a video game you know watching
the cutscenes and moving on to the next
step and I you know it felt like the
moment the plot begins things don't
really slow down and you know that's one
of the reasons why this feels like a
popcorn movie instead of like an
arthouse film
these are touts films do kind of slow
down and do kind of take those artistic
beats where is this felt like yeah you
know set piece after set piece after set
piece which you know if you really love
movies like Mad Max fury road or a baby
driver they kind of have that same kind
of pacing as well and to me I kind of
had that same kind of thrill ride rush
it feels like we should lift our filter
on spoilers yeah let's get into yeah so
if you haven't seen the movie
playing with fire skip out of the skip
ahead
real quick Devon have you seen it yet
yeah oh you did okay great alright then
we'll keep going about it who he has
seen the shining and who watched it
before ready to play what I had and I
know I got every single reference
because it's the shining but I that was
awesome that was really cool there's not
a witch woman in the know there's the
the woman in the bathtub
yeah so in this is one of the great
adaptations I think from the book if
you've read the book the the second key
I mean it's not whatever it's a spoiler
for the book super wherein the spoiler
section Wade has to reenact the movie
wargames line by line beat by be love
the movie war games but Spielberg
probably think what's the most visually
exciting thing I can do so instead he in
the writers adapted it to be they have
to go to the Overlook Hotel and and go
through the the maze that labyrinthian
hotel and be terrified and H as
characters like terrified by this movie
and doesn't haven't really seen it he
has no idea what it is but also I we did
notice had in the audience where we were
in the room there was like like audible
gas can be like oh my god and I honestly
felt that way too I was like this is the
coolest thing I've seen watched
everything and now I'm missing this
amazing moment so you don't know like
the any of the references with the shiny
the elevator I kind of got that but like
it's not that same vibe of like oh my
god like this is a thing that when I was
these characters aged recently i watch
this movie and what I love it's this
very specific thing that Spielberg does
a lot but the movies doing a lot it's
exposing children to a horror movie they
shouldn't be watching and that's exactly
how so many of us watch The Shining we
were way too young to watch it we were
curious about like there's nipples in it
and it's like yeah like I'm not supposed
to watch this but I'm like hiding and
watching it and it put them in that
exact same situation yeah
I just happened to have just seen this
with my girlfriend Valentine's Day
they'd like a special retro screening of
like she they saw The Shining they did a
special screen up in LA and this like
this big old-timey theater is screen and
it was awesome so like it was fresh on
my mind and like Spielberg must have
used like stock footage that's
definitely it look like Arlo or they did
effects to make it look like they went
to the original film stock because they
actually definitely do our digital
characters had film grain over there
yeah in those moments and they used like
the same music there's certain like pans
like the camera work the angles he must
have like three watched us and
shot-for-shot try to recreated it with
the same like music stings it was like
eerie just to see these characters
dropped in this world that's much too
from Spielberg to Kubrick because the
whole directing lives that they had they
were almost trying to one-up each other
but also they were so inspired by each
other's work so they had their own very
particular way of filming and then I
think it was like Kubrick wanted to
maybe borrow from Spielberg from time to
time and then they tried to kind of
emulate each other's style but it
wouldn't work as much so there's this
absolute adoration that these two people
had for each other so for Steven
Spielberg to use this movie and then
take a Spielberg I'm sorry a Kubrick
movie and then planting his injection
it's like such a powerful thing when you
know their history in their relationship
that they've had like and I know that a
few people watching it like that was a
really emotional moment for them knowing
the history that they have yeah I might
take I didn't know any of that that
makes that so really even flare to it
which but for me I was just like that
would be the main reason I'd use the
Oasis I wouldn't like I mean unless loot
the world not sure how the world outside
of the Oasis were watching movies where
you get to just like walk around and
experience every little aspect I mean I
would try and get the fire
I know what that is I thought you're
talking about neverending story wouldn't
force that part like weird
I'd probably go there in giants in
Sciences in this and I would just kind
of like hang out I'd be like friends
with the kid be like hey there's
definitely robot in the woods let's go
check that out I don't know if you can
talk to the characters I don't know how
it works that was the coolest that was
one of the coolest parts of the movie
for me it's pretty clear that like we
couldn't even like wait to talk about
that moment that at that moment was to
me bigger than this movie yeah this
movie is like it's like fine and I keep
telling people go watch it definitely
but there's this one thing that's like
one of the best things I've seen in
years and at anything now we probably
have to get to some grapes yeah and I
think that that joy that I felt watching
that moment almost felt undercut by what
that went into they go into the Gold
Room the the big Ballroom in the
Overlook Hotel and it becomes a very
generic forgettable thing where it's
just kind of like a video game challenge
with like zombies stuff and they have to
jump across and I mean I like the
emotional arc but it felt like they
there's too many times in this movie
where it just felt like too generic
video game stuff and I don't know about
you guys I know there's a lot of people
who love watching like twitch speedruns
video games it's not interesting for me
to watch other people play video Guide
to be a courier of time and he found it
yeah some of them are exciting but in
general it's like it's a different
experience than like having your
emotions connect with a character on
screen and watching them achieve their
their goals it's just it's a different
thing when I watch a movie I want to be
emotionally invested and I think ready
player one did the best possible job
that it could with that it's just like
it's too hard like when the finale to
continue talked about spoilers finale is
part of all plane and Atari game and
like people around the world they do
that cliche thing and people watching
screens around the world and instead of
like you know cooler things where like
people to blow up an asteroid that's
about to hit Earth
it's like someone playing a video game
and it would be interesting if Spielberg
found a way to like use that as like a
comment unlike our society now but it
seemed like he genuinely want us wanted
us to be one of those people watch but
it's kind of see okay a lot of people
I've been talking to you have some
assembly grab to that where it's like
they wanted the movie to speak to a
bigger problem with fan culture but this
movie in the book doesn't
as far as I know doesn't do that it's a
problem it's a it's just like porn
basically and that's what this movie
kind of is for references and stuff it's
like and I personally I didn't think
that was gonna happen but I do hear that
that is some eighth complaint that has
been coming up a lot from different
people yeah which is totally fair did at
a certain point this movie you're like
okay what's happening like seriously I
think that the what's tough about
listening gripes that this movie is like
I feel like it you're kind of missing
the point a little bit of like oh I
didn't have this I didn't have that so
that's my little preamble before I say
guys I actually don't don't feel that
strongly about these but as a film then
you do have to look at it and it feels
like it is missing some things and I'll
just throw it it's kind of a little bit
of what you just said with like that
video game kind of moment to cap the
shining sequence it's a good example of
a lot of times the stakes felt really
about as important as it feels to lose
in a video game and they did the effort
at the beginning of trying to show wow
when people lose in these games they
lose all their earned coins and whatnot
so the guy was like suicidal but then he
didn't kill himself the agent
businessman or whatever it was but that
still didn't feel like Real Estate's
especially because our characters didn't
actually suffer that so if part of all I
had lost everything and we had to see
that you know him you know earning his
way back up from a you know brand-new
carrot or something maybe I would have
felt it there they did eventually add
people getting murdered in real life
which I thought okay this feels like
real stakes but it was a little little
too little too late especially cuz it
wasn't attached to people dying in real
life mattering in the game in the game
it's just like we're still trying to do
this simple thing and so really that's
what the whole movie is about is what
they're trying to do in the game and at
the end of the day it's like we want to
own a company I'm like that didn't feel
very attached to me to exact specific
it's almost like trying to win the
lottery it's like great I hope you win
it's going to make your life better it
doesn't it feels like if you don't win
this place I have no real attachment to
because it's not actually real is going
to get worse it's gonna have more ads
but I'd need characters to get hurt and
that's what I need to feel I know all it
was was that your display screen would
be filled up with 80% ads which is a
great joke and I think it was a
throwaway almost joke right it's like no
no
this is the actual problem if I that's
the bad thing that could happen so how
in the hell does this world not have
BOTS running around inside of it like
you mean that this this game is not
perfect there's no company out there
making a is there like they'll walk
around they look like Hello Kitty or
something like hey did you know if you
send me 500 then good that's a dress
because it's not addressed in the movie
and I'm like how is there not already a
million ads in this but yeah it's uh you
know a lot of people compare this to
Willy Wonka the Chocolate Factory
Charlie chuckle Factory the book the
this idea this eccentric you know
inventor who is trying to pass off his
fortune and his company to an heir and
you know as much as I loved Mark Rylance
his portrayal of James Halliday he's got
this like interesting and introverted
like you know he's also super endearing
like he should have been a total like he
should be kind of creepy a little bit
but like we're we literally have to
relive every single one of his memories
to like get that like that's right and
that's right you know he did the best
possible job as an actor with that
character as the character is written
both in the book and in the movie it has
this weird kind of self fascination
that's kind of like hero-worship of this
character that like what has he really
done you know and why why are all the
truths to life like in this one
fictional character that like is just
kind of a weird guy with Willy Wonka
yeah we saw his dark side he's kind of
creepy it wasn't so much fascinated with
Willy Wonka as it was like with the
vices of the characters and seeing them
punished in interesting ways and seen
like the wondrous world he created but
this seems just a little too self
obsessed with like a character that
basically Ernest Cline created as a
version of his psyche that he wish he
was right and I would say that that's
part of the reason why we don't feel the
movie as we're watching the movie we're
enjoying it but we don't actually feel
those stakes it's because we're caring
about the history and past and secret
reveals of a character that we've spent
four minutes with or something meanwhile
our main character who we spent all this
time with we don't really learn anything
more about him we learn everything we
need to know about him from a very long
narration at the beginning and then
throughout could you imagine if the
whole thing was he had to go back to his
own childhood or something and
rediscover clues of like when he played
this game and it
like that's the same to his dad laughter
so you know whatever it is like if we're
exploring his own life but someone we
care about it totally would've worked on
me yeah looking at like taking the bet
Back to the Future approach right like
Marty goes back to his past and looks at
like oh I didn't need to be the hero in
that moment I could have made the
smarter choice you know two people that
are very important to him his own
parents and revisiting that yeah if he
had ended up being his dad or something
of course you know that'd be a little
contrived but at the same time it'd be
like Oh at least it mattered but that's
all Moody's could try to give this
Steven Spielberg Alan Silvestri the
composer Back to the Future is composing
this movie like it's pretty often
yeah yeah you do if in fact we're gonna
be doing like an in-depth breakdown of
all the Easter eggs that your award how
it's big give a shout out to the
animation like honestly the way that
they did the CGI that was the thing that
I was worried about and I played a lot
of video games where they just can't get
it they just cannot get it even if they
have the mocap even if they've got all
the little bits and bops it's always
just a little clunky or a little bit
like the walking's just not normal this
one was so well done there's physicality
is really incredible mannerisms there
was likeness there was you know
close-ups where you see all their face
move like I was super super thrilled
with that part apparently there's so
much animation in this movie that it
might be a hoe no more than 80% of it
probably your sweet animated material
but the lego movie had less live-action
stuff in it and it didn't get nominated
no wasn't a parent and I know it didn't
you got for the music it didn't get the
nomination was it seeking the nomination
yeah different animation and maybe the
one every part but I remember that was
like a thing they added on to it they're
like well since there's Will Ferrell
walking around in it being Will Ferrell
with that kid it's like it doesn't count
that's best that sounds like the
Academy's saying like we don't want to
give Ana nomination to a commercial
movie that's selling a popular toy brand
yeah but it's different with Spielberg
you know you know this is cyborg in
training like hi Sheridan has just had a
visor on his face last year olds and
he's gonna do it again they don't like
his eyes
greatly tonita says but his eyes is what
they call him in the industry I will say
that I guess at least like I gasped at
least five times when I recognized
reference and that and I at the same
time I was like damn it cuz that means
they got me like 100% like there was
like Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
there's Blue Beetle from DC Comics we
saw a tracer from overwatch like three
or four Gundam showed up I was like yeah
i neva know watched I just remember the
Toonami commercials when I was a kid it
was like Evie's dad after dark not hard
to networking and watch it and when the
team's meeting into AI said that one and
the t-rex from Jurassic Park when that
should have in the race was that the
t-rex and dress hardly even though we're
like yeah and it's great Spielberg was
like I didn't want to make any
references to my own movies that be so
known because it made the same roar and
it's the same shot of it chasing the
t-rex yeah that's racist but I think
that's by the way that's honestly what
I'll throw that under the grape list
really quick they get Spielberg to the
right and it's like holy crap like the
best director from that era is directing
this movie and he says I don't really
want to make a lot of references to
myself and it's like you're the best
movie you made all the movies also
however they shot or not shucks it's all
fake but like me the the race in the
beginning is like one of the coolest
it's just non-stop in it for some people
they're like I couldn't even focus on
anything it's like that's the point yeah
you could look anywhere in this scene
and something's happening and that takes
a lot of care and effort so yeah I'll
I'll pause it a question for you all or
just maybe pose one the idea of looking
at every part of the screen and finding
something interested is it overwhelming
is it exciting to go back and watch
again like how do you feel about that
idea of Easter eggs in general which is
kind of our lifeline like when to do
this like it's a it's meant to be
watching million times so you get
everything or is it like please just
give me a story to focus on and to
central characters I think when I review
anything whether it's a video game
movie one of the key factors for me is
rewatch ability or replayability you
want and done or is this the movie that
can keep giving and I haven't seen this
movie twice now mmm was just eyes
jumping all over the place and I loved
it and I loved discovering new things
every single time so having that
replayability and rewatch ability is a
really good thing yeah I think it
depends on the movie right like if
you're adapting ready player one you
better load it with every inch of
pop-culture reference that you can the
the trick is is so long as it doesn't
become distracting I think Spielberg
sends some interview and are in
screenings he's like he wanted the
references to be like you know when
you're looking out the window of the
DeLorean or the train or whatever you're
on you see the images the reference is
passing by you but the story is the road
or the track that was awful that was so
bad I was like it's a weapon that's
amazing that's what you just throw it in
the middle of a battle and it just if
you can play a great video game like I
grew up playing like the Tomb Raider
games and you could just play the
narrative but if you really wanted to
play it a second time they put little
secrets and easter eggs in there so for
two people or for any two people one
could just be wanted to play that simple
narrative and you can want to explore
the world for argument sake I'll just
throw out there reminder how much we
love Logan sure and how it's like kind
of purposely trying to be like let's
take a break from the world right and
some some stories you don't want that
and I think yeah Logan's a good example
was your favorite little geek reference
in it because mine was going on from
Mortal Kombat's
was that in the bat and the fire was it
just walking around that was the skin
that she used as her disguise yeah with
that then my favorite was when she used
the chest burster as no I love the
little tennis ball in the shining
because it's such as like a small not
memorable moment from The Shining unless
like you're a huge fan of it but it's
just like a little thing that like
anyone who really did watch it's gonna
be like alright yeah yeah I think it's
those references that were in the score
that we were talking about for me we're
like I remember sitting there in the
theater and we were you know there was a
moment right before the shining moment
which was my most moment but I had like
these like butterflies in my stomach
when I would hear the little magical
kind of wispy nosov Back to the Future
man that just like brought
to a visceral reaction which is pretty
rare for a movie we can talk about this
movie all day but we have to move on
there's so many things we got to talk
about today so let's move on to this
week's trivia question our Ian's keep
things ready player one themed and ready
player one wait / pars of all tricks
Nolan Sorento with trivia about the
fictional high school in The Breakfast
Club was also the same high school in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off what is the
name of that high school just as a
reminder the stakes later in the show
will read the answer the question the
closest answer has to decide by our
judges sounds like mods got it
we'll do our sign off goodbyes at the
end of the video she can do whatever she
wants to do in terms of her voice
the loser book I mean a lot of loser
why endure another news headlines and be
super funny since this is Newark sirs
news we want to cover everything that
you need to know so you'd have to go
looking at a bunch of other websites you
can just watch this video get all the
details after the trailer for Aquaman
did not come out last weekend as it was
rumored to director James Wan actually
went on Twitter with an explanation he
said that the trailer release was never
actually on the books as is often the
case with fan rumors and he say he's not
really ready to share footage because of
the movies heavy visual effects they are
just taking forever to animate and to
render and he doesn't want to put all
anything out there that seems subpar but
no one does right now why sometimes the
studio is just rushing it and one put
his foot down and he said that he is
working nonstop on the movie and he put
a bunch of fun aquatic puns in those
tweets he said I misread it and it was
like I'm putting gills on everybody I'm
like why there's so many Gila for give
yourself a break don't do that
yeah alright guys let's move on to some
Star Wars news an unnamed actor from
solo a Star Wars story was interviewed
by vulture and he confirmed many of the
troubling rumors that we heard about the
movies production he called previous
directors Phil Lord and Chris Miller
inefficient he said that they did 30
takes of a scene at times with often the
only note between takes to be play it
different to them before this guy also
said that new director Ron Howard took
the reins in a good way and that
production improved dramatically but
it's impossible to know how good the
final movie will be until the final cut
is seen meanwhile this anonymous source
also confirmed the rumors
Alden Ehrenreich sakteng saying that the
studio did hire an acting coach to help
him mimic Harrison Ford's delivery and
that the coaching actually really helped
now my question for you guys this news
make you any more or less worried about
the Han Solo movie or do you think that
these are productions struggles that are
just on a lot of movies and Star Wars
leaks are just more likely to make the
news because it's Star Wars I thought
yeah I thought this definitely sounded
like a plant sorry go ahead I am worried
about this whole bosses future because
he's not an actor they're gonna find you
mean the sort oh the the leak so it was
supposedly someone who is prominent
enough that they were part of the
reshoots right so it's not just like a
random background actually it would be
it sounded like a plan though cuz
they're like no the milk crystal or Phil
Miller was definitely bad Ron Howard
definitely fixed it we just don't know
but as soon as they said something about
the actor it's like oh I wouldn't have
why did you do this interview like
seriously why did you do this interview
that's so happy yeah they are why didn't
ya I'll say I think that yeah you know
I'll be the optimist on this one and say
that you know a lot of movies have
problems and I actually do think that if
they were able to identify the problems
a lot of times you're too inside of it
and you can't figure out what's wrong
but if they're able to be like to be
clear too by the way they said it's not
that his acting was bad as it was his
ability to channel Harrison Ford doing
han Solo
do like he's acting fine he's just not
acting like Harrison Ford so they
brought him on to help him channel the
original Han Solo more and they said
they did it and they thought it was a
success and then also that Ron Howard
reshot everything that they thought
wasn't good so at the worst version of
this I think we're just getting a Ron
Howard directed solo movie and so I'm
like that's pretty good I would've been
fairly excited for that you know the
first place invokes are they or I think
in the deadline version of the vulture
article there like they hired an acting
coach which never happens
like there are people whose jobs are to
be acting teachers and acting coaches
and for tasks as complex as mirroring
Harrison Ford's iconic specific delivery
which only really Harrison Ford can do
like that's a really difficult do it in
a way that other people would be like
that's Han Solo I don't it doesn't
surprise me if they hired an acting
coach it also doesn't surprise me that
you do 30 takes especially in comedy you
do take after taking improv based comedy
I mean look at any of the Apatow movies
did have have you watched the ever like
the extras whatever they have hours of
extra fun even like Parks and Rec they
would shoot like 90 hours of footage per
episode you're like wow that's a lot of
footage you did not use and definitely
didn't make it to the DVD after you it's
not that away either it's not just
comedy like David Fincher is known for
doing take I could take I mean he's the
perfectionist he's looking for something
different sometimes like you know a
little muscle tic under the eye wasn't
perfect and he'll just be like do it
again and Rick I think this sounds like
oh the only note was that to do a
different I don't buy that that sounds
like someone who's making a general
statement like oh they just did another
take and always said do a different I've
been on sets before and sometimes it
does seem like the director is like God
do they really need to do another takes
was probably some actor who's working
long hours and said he felt annoyed that
these guys like who would these comedy
guys is doing another take to do another
he's new art behind the camera you are
watching the playback footage you don't
know what's really in screen usually I
think psychologically us knowing about
this it might translate in a way where
we detect something that we're half
inventing maybe half detecting I almost
like feel like if we had not known that
there were any issues waiting a lot he's
definitely working really hard to do
that impressions like knives is probably
hot in the desk okay well another quick
update from the news this week moving on
here Marvel Comics had a big
announcement this week saying that the
Fantastic Four will come back to the
comics in August 2018 with a new series
written by Dan slide and illustrated by
Sarah Pacelli
it's the first time the whole team the
four of them have been brought together
in the comics since the Secret Wars in
the 80s now rumor has it that Marvel was
hesitant to make any
for comics it's a movie rights to the
characters were owned by 20th Century
Fox and maybe they didn't want to over
popularize the characters that they
couldn't make money from but I have a
raspy vote folks and a throat but now
that this merger between Fox and
Disney's that's Marvel's parent company
is in the works it's not done yet but
it's still currently in the process some
guy made sure to really yell at me about
that fans are fans are speaking that
Fantastic Four's returned to the comics
could be a predictor of Marvel Studios
maybe rebooting the franchise under
their own brand at some point yes
definitely that's exactly what's
happening yeah really cool also it's
been sad I've missed them I hope they
were back in stories okay everybody
Donald Glover's animated Deadpool series
on TV that he created for FX was
cancelled by the network with sources
citing creative differences saying
Glover was parting ways with FX and
Marvel television and FX making a
comment about Glover not being able to
do it because we have a packed schedule
now Glover responded in the coolest way
possible he tweeted that he wasn't too
busy to work on Deadpool and he tweeted
a parody finale script of the animated
series it mocks the whole situation a
ton of other stuff in classic Deadpool
fashion now this was an actual script
for the show we don't think it might
have lifted some jokes or some plot
elements really this was a mock script
this was like a sample of like hey just
to show you that I did have time to work
on it here is a 14 page script with the
kind of tone and humor that you would
have seen had this show not been
cancelled well I thought we'd do
something fun here guys
do something a little bit different I
think we would actually read the script
with all of you as a staged reading with
the four of us to play all the parts
it's only 14 pages we have we have the
scripts printed out here there's only
four characters and it's hilarious it's
to be really great now again this is not
our work the the script was written by
Donald Glover and his brother who Co
collaborates with but Glover did tweet
it out there for the world to see so
hopefully he won't mind so just to do
some casting here Phillip will be
reading our exposition and action for
the script I will read for Deadpool mod
will read for the roles of
as Ian Keith I'm a damn [ __ ] and blind
al and Sam will read for the character
of Zachary little pivotal role and just
put that on there pivotal Zechariah is
the name though not pivotal now what
we're about to do right now is just a
short little sample you'll see it in
this video but if you want to see us
read the entire 14 page script it's it's
super hilarious we're gonna be
re-releasing this full segment as its
own uninterrupted segment that you can
watch later this weekend so keep an eye
out for that okay is it one ready take
away Phillip I'm silent okay Deadpool
the animated series finale written by
Donald Glover exterior Kenyon Savannah
Day Deadpool is asleep in a jeep that's
driving down a dirt road he's sitting
next to an African woman who looks in
her late 30s as young keiki Deadpool
suddenly wakes up screaming don't let
Ben Carson are operate on me where the
hell am i you're in Kenya I picked you
up from the airport you were very drunk
when I arrived security helped me carry
you to the car doesn't sound like me and
it takes a lot to get me drunk you were
passed out in an empty duty-free oh yeah
you guys are the ones with the Rhino yes
I'm Sen keke gypos jocose J Kazuki jay-z
and Kiki you know what I'm just gonna
call you the Greek freak and John Kiki
frowns doesn't seem cool Deadpool
ignores it yeah so y'all paid me in
Bitcoin I'm surprised so you were the
first to agree to that whatever it takes
we're surprised you took the job
actually you don't seem like the animal
lover type oh don't get me wrong I'd rip
that horn off myself if a poacher paid
me enough
I'm Jeremy Meeks when it comes to that
bag oh but I also love everything right
now you know I used to wear a ton of
echo back in the day I was a huge g-unit
fan had the whole fit still got some
shirts you want some echo shirts no yeah
me neither
so where's this big grey nutsack skin
covered unicorn we're hiding in Sudan
right now he's very weak we've been
doing all we can but if he stays in
captivity he will die
problem is the poachers they're
everywhere and I've been waiting for oh
my god you see what Sanne Lathan bit
Beyonce's face wait oh thank god
it was Jennifer Lawrence I already hate
her it's fine he continues to scroll and
stare at his phone as in Kiki keeps
driving awkwardly you're driving
awkwardly he looks for a moment then
goes back to scrolling it's an addiction
so if it seems like I'm not paying
attention to you it's because I agree
the what you say exterior mountainside
day the Jeep pulls through brush and
into a clearing there are 20 armed
guards in uniform blocking a tunnel
opening they let the Jeep pass through
and they park in the tunnel the Jeep is
blasting rubbing off the paint by ybn
Namir as they pull in that's always
interesting
yeah that's my [ __ ] really him and rich
the kid is all I really listened to
lately rich the kid not as much so he be
cloud chasing wow this is cool well not
actually cool but like Vegas cool
chainsmokers cool who are you talking to
the people watching the people reading
this you made it
Zechariah mu Phi walks over hello I'm
Zechariah Sudan's keeper we really
appreciate you doing this don't thank me
thank the 700 bitcoins are paying me oh
my god it dropped that much
I went from Johnny Depp in Pirates of
the Caribbean to Johnny Depp in Pirates
of the Caribbean the ride deadpool
pinches the bridge of his nose and
frustrated frustration where's this
interior mountain tunnel day a large
rhino stands eating by a rock wall
Deadpool as young Kiki and Zechariah
walk up to him this is Sudan the last
male northern white rhino on the earth
hi when he dies a piece of us dies as
well this is a me die all the time it's
fine also can't you guys just grab some
rhino semen and make more rhinos we
prefer to do it naturally but in case
something does happen to him in the wild
we did have semen samples taken so this
isn't even really the last male rhino
y'all can Jurassic Park that whenever
you want this feels like a waste of my
time I assure you it isn't whatever what
you'd be doing instead wouldn't be as
significant a be jaqen llamas from
eleven-year-olds Zechariah Neji and Kiki
stare what fortnight hello
Oh Jack and llamas from eleven-year-old
sounds awful that's not what I'm saying
I'm not takashi 69 i'm an amazing rapper
zechariah Neji and Kiki are still
confused Wow
nothing's landing her cultures are very
different we have so much to teach each
other exterior African savannah day a
large flatbed released his Sudan out
into the open the armed guards rally
around and make sure he's safe as Jen
kiki and Zechariah away from the teeth
be careful we only need you to follow
him until he mates then you can collect
your price I gotta follow him until he
mates man this job this ain't worth it
bitcoin status alert holy Jeff Bezos I
will protect him with my life
that was great now that we're finished
reading what do you guys think this show
would have looked like on TV what do you
think that we're missing out on the most
it's it's a bummer
I think there's our since I do some
superhero TV review shows I'm like well
I think this one actually sounded very
original and hey since it's FX it
couldn't been that many episodes I would
have been pretty sure like archers what
like eight episodes 10 episodes tops but
it's a bummer because it's always good
to see more stuff from Donald Glover I
love it Lana right now yeah and it would
have been awesome but what can you do
bummed about is how these people are
talking to each other publicly that's
never good yeah exactly it's weird that
he has problems with FX like FX threw
him under the bus I'm like but you guys
have a show together yeah won an Emmy
what do you doing
seems pretty burned and I'm not
surprised that in the script if you if
you saw a full reading of it he I think
he's not kidding when he says it could
have been a racial thing and I don't
mean that in terms of like him saying
like oh it's because I'm black it's he's
from what we just read is saying the
show felt pretty black it was a lot of
black writers on the staff he you know
was a black version of the character and
maybe the I mean I don't think he's
kidding he says maybe they interpreted
that it's a little too black of a take
on Deadpool that's
real quick I am bummed the shows not
happening cuz one it kind of reminds me
of spawn if you guys remember one one
spawn was on TV it was just like this
like super adult cartoon hero but it is
actually not tongue-in-cheek about being
a superhero kind of like anything on
Adult Swim is like is aware that it is
doing up this is an actual show but the
other thing is I I think that they were
missing on the opportunity to make
another take on Deadpool he breaks the
fourth wall it should be influenced by
whoever's playing him right it shouldn't
be a Ryan Reynolds impression if Donald
Glover is doing Deadpool then it should
be a Donald Glover Deadpool because it
breaks the fourth wall big bummer yeah
and yeah I think that it was a poor
decision to cancel whatever the reasons
were behind it
Donald clubber clearly has a great take
on the character in terms of like the
commentary and the humor and even the
way Ryan Reynolds has done the
characters in the character in the
movies it's it's very like aware of like
the current culture and current events
and he's referencing all kinds of things
and I feel like this wasn't too removed
from that and had a whole different
angle and it could have been a great
thing to explore beyonce face biting was
in the last few days right have two
written this like would be a busy guy
seem to be like screw you I'm not too
busy and actually dedicate the time to
put it out there that is it that's a
middle finger yeah yeah for sure well
comment down below to let us know what
you thought about this the script and
enbe channel on her at least by a hectic
is I felt like I got all these great
jobs but and what part of Donnell
Glover's take on Deadpool that you're
most bummed about missing out on and as
reminders subscribe to new rock stars
for news and insight into all the stuff
that you love Deadpool the general
Marvel news everything thanks everybody
and then we'll put a little pause here
as we move on to the lightning round and
we can start to move these away I would
say okay well now it is time to move on
to our new rock stars news lightning
round
you guys were so great and you uh you
were nice enough to take the time to
tweet us some questions I'm collecting
some of them when gunfire them at my
co-host we have to answer them as
quickly as possible no hesitation
allowed is everyone ready
boners yes here we go starting for Sam
at HP Bateman wants to know who
be your ideal cast for a Fantastic Four
movie in MCU that's the whole cast yes
quick checklist bring up anything
interesting Johnny Storm right Sheridan
Stanfield he played a really like kind
of like he had like like evil genius
vibe in Death Note and I'd be kind of
interesting Human Torch we did okay
around keeps moving for Phillip at Sage
a Nelson wants to know what are you most
looking forward to with Marvel phase
four and why Marvel phase four the
biggest change that I'm actually
genuinely excited about is doing the
whole thing again with the x-men mixed
in yeah like they can do that now right
Disney Fox they got married a baby
please yeah for mud if you live in any
TV show could live in any TV show what
would it be and why that Miley Manriquez
wants to know TV shows yeah any TV shows
and um TV that I would want to live in
gosh waiting wait wait make pressure
whitening I'm not
the ones I'm watching at the moment oh
look let's just do sort out online sure
what is it online I'm watching anime
again seeing as you have the coolest
surname ever alright if you could choose
any one fiction or nonfiction to be your
partner in a buddy cop movie who would
it be
in other words complete this title blank
in the boss by at one Chipko that's the
question before hey why I'm blinkin a
boss like in the boss and I want to
rhyme it okay in the world thank you
know it's funny that we like force
ourselves to be past you probably just
want like thought out enhancing my cast
is a weird spattering of people oh it's
so great and pitbull in the boss
crossover event right none this
animation that mod I'm excited
hey guys actually um we're gonna look
into launching a new Q&A format where
you know we can interact with you guys
more directly more frequently so keep an
eye out for future announcements and
requests on twitter by following us at
new rock stars thank you everybody
um but next up let's take a look at what
we got in the pipeline for videos coming
out on this channel in the next week so
we mentioned before we have a ready
player one Easter egg breakdown we're
gonna try to get all 8,000 of those good
luck and then of course we're gonna be
doing a breakdown of the Walking Dead
episode 14 and Sam's continuing as emcee
rewind
yes I did guardians the galaxy did age
of Ultron which you guys seemed to
respond very well to which is awesome so
next obviously a good little button at
the end of phase 2 ant-man so check that
out it's a that's a fun movie that was a
fun one to do hopefully enjoy your
Easter eggs ill and yeah we don't have
anything on the books for sure but we
have like we're approaching the summer
movie season guys in April we're gonna
be starting to see a lot more trailers
hopefully James Wan will have his
Aquaman trailer ready or
he's probably seen more stuffer ant-man
in the wasp and and they moved back Dark
Phoenix along with you know they music
for yeah we want you see a trailer for
that but now comes the time for a
15-second shout out where each of us has
15 seconds to shout out plug ramble
about anything we want Sam why you start
I want to give a shout out I'll give a
shout to you guys you guys have been
supporting the MC Yuri watches and
that's a really fun for me to do
sometimes it's crazy because the movies
aren't good but there's still great
little Easter eggs in them so makes it
still fun so I'm glad you guys enjoy
them and I will figure out what to do
after they're done because they're
almost near the end you did there like
two weeks ago - well they're better
shout to the editors who edit those
because I they don't there's a tunnel in
there and I sorry I just curse a lot to
bleep yeah bleep the little bleep but
you guys make it and very entertaining
for the people watching yeah and thank
you guys you're over there I will shout
out the season five of Silicon Valley I
love that show and we actually did a
video breakdown of although they have a
ton of little Easter eggs in the
ten-second opening credits scene and not
enough of you've seen it people in this
room saw it and that's about it you're
right right but if I love love love that
show and if even if you don't watch the
video that I make super funny it's super
funny watch watch Eric's video I'm gonna
give I'm gonna split my 15 seconds one
something you need to get on is if you
haven't watched the Americans it just
started the final season and they did a
really cool time jump so that it's like
not even the same show anymore exactly
the Americans one of the best shows on
TV
Bar None and then the other thing is
I'll tell you you don't need to go see
Tommy why those in the movie oh just
watch the room again I had a bucket list
tick interview already play one was it
cool he's so great guys he's amazing
I did the best bits compilation talking
about Mendo so because I'm Australian
Mendoza Australian Mende would call
Spielberg dad on set and like that who
wouldn't for the uninitiated Mendo is
Mendelssohn there's been men and dad so
I kind of got to the bottom of all that
a bit yeah he was that was it was great
guys I didn't have an Oprah moment where
I was like so as his weapon plateaued
subscribers for like the last four
months I need all my friends to do well
yeah check out all these things check
out geek mom check out only stupid
answer thank you
yeah and let's give everyone some love
you know and finally let's return to our
trivia question that we asked earlier
what it was yeah okay so in ready player
one Wade slash parts of all tricks know
in Toronto with trivia about the
fictional high school in The Breakfast
Club it was also the same high school in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off what was the
name of that high school and let's go
down the line and see lightning I was so
motivated Fremont High Bri montage Eric
and the boss John Hughes High School
which is actually a joke made in Not
Another Teen Movie that's so stolen joke
Phillips says Sherman high school which
also sounds accurate well and then my
wrote sure ma that's cool pretty close
and then she wrote her general so
Shermer pretty close the correct answer
is
Shermer high school sh t in RM e are
accent scheme' pretty clear yeah all
right judges who was the closest pretty
obvious that Eric is well your answer
was negated because your stolen mod is
the winner will do our good-byes and
she'll make fun of our names if she
could to see whatever voice she wants to
do tank yeah just suggestion and then
we're gonna quickly run through our in
other news headlines we didn't have time
for a big news this week I'm gonna have
to make jokes will have another host
read that would you like to join the set
up and then and I'll have to be funny so
in other news this week and I'm gonna
buy Eric a little bit of time as he
reads into the story Game of Thrones
actor Pedro Pascal who played the Viper
oberyn martell he's going to play an
unknown key role in the upcoming Wonder
Woman sequel ooh
talk about mind-blowing news the Viper
bites both ways
spider-man actor Tom Holland said he was
not allowed to read the full script for
Avengers infinity war because he
revealed way too many secrets about
spider-man homecoming while promoting
that movie
yep just keep those spoilers off the web
they can spider related things maybe
Brno stolen something three x-men Dark
Phoenix and the new mutants were pushed
back in the schedule to February in
August 2019 with extensive reshoots
being required for both of those movies
mmm schedule storm that is a reference
to Marvel's storm character and director
Colin Trevorrow I will direct the third
Jurassic world movies coming back
despite stepping down from directing
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom mm well if
we know anything about sequels Trevorrow
never dies
[Music]
Rick and Morty creators Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland my nipple tweeted to fans
that the show's fourth season has not
been approved by Adult Swim but they're
confident it will be after the network
decides on new ways to monetize it
oh and as the fans are torn between
their love and their over obsessive hate
of the show they're caught in quite of a
pickle Rick if you don't just bomb like
I normally do that's a great doctor said
please stop having him do this blood
pressure kind of skyrocket at two weeks
ago I mean toy winding goodbye hey ma
take it away
[Music]
no the winning is always the worst part
my last name is Garrett GA mm tt we're
not forcing her to do this I love it
just give a shout out to all our socials
as this fourth-grade rapper hungry
alright another shout-out to our editors
see if you can make that work hey guys
comment down below tweet us that new
rock stars like this video share it
around subscribe to new rockstars deep
no boomer click bye